دوله اوروبيه كانت يوما مع جزء من الاتحاد
السوفيتي ومثل معظم الدول اللي مثلها
البلد مقسومه ناس مع روسيا والناس ضد
وميالين لاوروبا والغرب والدوله يعني من
الدول الطامحه في الانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي ومقدم طلب في هذا الخصوص لكن
الدنيا جورجيا حاليا مولعه تظاهرات والسبب
العلاقات مع روسيا القصه انه في 2019 قامت
مظاهرات في تبليسي ضد موسكو فقامت موسكو
وحضرت الطيران مع جورجيا من كم يوم بدون
سابق انذار انذار طلع بوتين واعلن استئناف
الطيران مع جورجيا مو بس كده لكن كمان قال
انه الجورجيين ما يحتاجوا فيزا لدخول
روسيا اكثر من الجورجيين مو عاجبهم
الموضوع وطلعوا مظاهرات اشتبكوا مع الشرطه
ولعت الدنيا في الشوارع ومعظم المحتاجين
خايفين يكون هذا مدخل لتوسيع نفود روسيا
في البلد او ان الموضوع يؤثر على طلب
الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي الاشتباكات هذه
انتقلت من الشارع ووصلت كمان لقبه
البرلمان اللي النواب في
مسكو في بعض شيء مع او شيء ضد استئناف
الطيران مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القرار وحساباتها مشغله اعتراض على القرار
لكن الاكثار ما يعرفونه بجورجيا منصب رئيس
الدوله منصب شرفي واللي بيحكم فعليا هو
الحكومه ورئيسها ورئيس الحكومه مع القرار
وميال لروسيا كل اللي قلت لكم هذا هو
خلفيه للخبر اللي جاي واللي حقيقه من اغرب
ما يكون فاللي صار انه رئيس جورجيا اعترضت
على القرار وقالت انه راح تقاطع الخطوط
الجورجيه لانها استانفت رحلاتها مع روسيا
لهنا نص العجب خلينا نشوف النص التالي
رئيس الدوله
طيران بلدها يعني لكن الاعجب انه شركه
الطيران ردت وقالت انه هي اللي راح تحضر
الرئيسه من استقلال طائراتها وسمتها شخص
غير مرغوب فيه وقالت لا ترى ما حنشيل
الحظر الى ان تعتذري من الشعب